الان الى التطورات في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
حيث اعتدت قوه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على
عدد من اهالي بلده حوار جنوبيه نابلس خلال
تفريقها وقفه تردد بالاستيطان وكانت قوه
الاحتلال قد عززت من وجودها العسكري في
البلده رغم ان البلده تخضع لحصار عسكري
جزئي
وتنظم المظاهره من اجل فك الحصار على بلده
حواره ومسانده الاهالي الذين يتعرضون
لهجمات متتاليه ومنظمه من قبل المستوطنين
بحمايه جنود الاحتلال بزعم تنفيذ
المقاومين الفلسطينيين عددا من العمليات
على الشارع الرئيس للبلده كما تنظم
مظاهرات في عدد من القرى المجاوره كبلدتي
بيتا وبيت دجن احيانا للذكرى السابعه
والاربعين ليوم الارض الذي يجسد حمايه
الارض الفلسطينيه من الاستيطان
الحوار جنوب مدينه نابلس مراسله الجزيره
جبار المدير لتنقل لنا المشهد كاملا
ازدهار قوات الاحتلال قمعت المتظاهرين
الذين تواجدوا هنا ولكن كما نرى هناك
دوريات عسكريه لاذرع مختلفه لقوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من خلال شكل الدوريات
العسكريه نستطيع ان نقول ونؤكد ان هناك من
حرس الحدود من جنود الاحتلال من المخابرات
الاسرائيليه الذين يعملون هنا بالطبع تم
تعزيز وجود قوات الاحتلال منذ ساعات
الصباح بعد الدعوه التي وجهتها اللجنه
الوطنيه
للمقاومه الشعبيه بالطبع لفك الحصار
الجزئي هنا عن بلده حواره المتواصل بعد
العمليه التي نفذها مقاومين فلسطينيين
وادت الى اصابه جنديين اسرائيليين ولكن
بالطبع ايضا
للذكرى لاحياء الذكرى السابعه والاربعين
ليوم الارض الذي بالطبع هو بنظر
الفلسطينيين لم يحدث فقط هذا في داخل الخط
الاخضر ولكن هو يتواصل كل يوم كما هي
النكبه الفلسطينيه من خلال تعزيز
الاستيطان نحن نتحدث عن هذا الشارع
الرئيسي ازدهار هو شارع يربط جنوب مدينه
نابلس في شمال الضفه الغربيه بوسط الضفه
الغربيه ولكن المستوطنين هنا يمرون
بحمايه قوات الاحتلال الان بدا سلطات
الاحتلال باذرعها المختلفه تامين الشوارع
المحيطه ببلده حواره بالقرى القريبه
بالدجن وبيتا فقط لتامين مرور امن
للمستوطنين ولكن الاع هو على الفلسطينيين
وعلى الاهالي على السيارات التي تتنقل
للفرنس والتنقل الفلسطينيين من وسط الضفه
الغربيه الى الشماليها ولكن ما رايناها
اليوم كان هناك اعتداء على الصحفيين
اعتداء على الاطفال كانوا داخل المسجد
خرجوا بعد اداء صلاه الجمعه الثانيه من
الشهر الفضيل تم الاعتداء على شاب فلسطيني
بالضرب المبرح ومن ثم تم اعتقال هذا الشاب
راينا عدد من المستوطنين الذين يتوقفون
هنا وما يريد فقط نسمع شتائم فقط اننا
نتحدث العربيه وكل الصحفيين تم الاعتداء
عليهم بطبع الان نوعا ما نستطيع الحركه في
الشارع الرئيسي
ولكن قبل حوالي الساعه لم نكن نستطيع
التحرك والتنقل
كما نرى المزيد من التعزيزات العسكريه تصل
الى هنا فقط لنذكر ازدهار نحن نتحدث عن
هذه البلده هي بلده صغيره ولكن هي اصبحت
من احد اهم الاسماء التي يتم تداول اسمها
على المستوى الدولي بعد المحرقه التي
نفذها المستوطنون هنا في نهايه شهر شباط
ومن ثم ما قاله وزير
الاسرائيلي بانه يجب محو بلدتي حواره عن
الوجود بزعم طبعا وقوع عمليه سابقه وقتل
فيها مستوطن ولكن كان ذلك بالنسبه
للفلسطينيين
عفوا لسلطات الاحتلال ذريعه لمواصله
اقتحام البلده والتي هي تعيش اصلا يعني
كما نرى هذا الشارع هو كله محلات تجاريه
الاهالي يعيشون
ويعتمدون على هذه المحاله التجاريه حتى من
خارج حوار اي من القرى المدن الرئيسيه
كرام الله نابلس جنين طولكرم قلقيليه هنا
اعتماد كبير على بلده حواره الان الخسائر
تزيد عن 20 مليون دولار سواء ما تم حرقه
من المحال التجاريه وبالطبع اكثر من 30
منزلا اضافه الى الاجراءات العسكريه كما
نرى لان الفلسطينيين اصبحوا يخشون كثيرا
المرور من هنا يعني نحن في الشهر الفضيل
كما نرى ازمه خانقه بسبب التواجد لقوات
الاحتلال وبالتالي الفلسطيني يضطر الان
الانتظار لساعات على فقط للمرور من حاجز
الى حاجز وفي حواره كل 100 متر على الاقل
هناك دوريه عسكريه
وجنود يقفون وبالتالي الحركه هنا بالنسبه
للفلسطينيين انا اصبحت وكان جحيم وخوف
وايضا للعائلات داخل منازلها التي قبل
قليل قوات الاحتلال اطلقت قنابل الغاز
داخل بعض هذه المنازل شكرا لك اذا من حوار
جنوب مدينه طرابلس الجزيره
جيفارا البوديري